[Music]
new york london and hong kong are by
most measures the world's top three
financial centres
other cities can claim to be part of the
conversation but if you're doing
business in the west you go to new york
or london
in asia you come to hong kong
but hong kong is in trouble on multiple
fronts politics and protests kovids and
china
and the problems are forcing everyone
hong kongers and expats alike to
re-examine whether the city can still
offer them what they need
and whether hong kong can maintain its
status as asia's premier financial
centre
hong kong is the ultimate gateway
between china and the rest of the world
the biggest thing that is going to
determine hong kong's success
is going to be the need for capital in
china
the beating heart of hong kong's
financial sector is a thin sliver of
land between the sea and the mountains
where banks and financial institutions
have clustered
retail giants like hsbc and standard
charted famous wall street names like
goldman sachs and jp morgan
and chinese rivals like citic and cicc
are among the dozens of banks that
populate central hong kong
they specialize in pulling in
institutional capital from around the
world and deploying it into chinese
companies
the prime recipient of these funds is
hong kong stock exchange
it's the fifth largest stock exchange in
the world
but what makes it stand out is that it's
the best and safest place to invest in
china
where the banks go others follow
insurers wealth managers stock brokers
hedge funds consultants and lawyers all
taking advantage of the world's appetite
for exposure to the chinese economy
while positioning themselves for the day
that china opens up its capital accounts
and permits access to a wallet worth 50
trillion dollars
hong kong is a city that is caught up in
this massive geopolitical
storm
there is no way to maintain hong kong's
reputation as an international financial
center
when you have
those type of upheavals in society it
makes it very uncertain for foreign
investors to come in
[Music]
finance is a lucrative business
every city in asia wants the same
high-value well-paid jobs as central
hong kong
but finance is also demanding yes it
requires deep pools of capital and a
strong financial infrastructure but it
also requires an attractive place for
people to live and that means stable
politics a happy society and the freedom
of people to move and the freedom of
information
until 2019 hong kong ticks all of those
boxes
but then long simmering discontents with
the territory's governments and its
relationship with mainland china changed
everything
it all started with a bill which was
proposed by the hong kong government
suggesting that
there would be extradition arrangements
between hong kong and mainland china
that the sense of betrayal was what
triggered hong kong people to protest
what triggered two million people more
than a quarter of the city's population
came out
scenes of clashes between
police and protesters
tear gas
using pepper spray produces throwing
petrol bombs for 3 4 months
in nearly every part of the city the
chinese government saw them as open
rebellions and therefore use
extra constitutional means to introduce
this national security law aiming at
outlawing acts of subversion succession
terrorism inclusion with foreign forces
hundreds of pro-democracy campaigners
and government opponents like student
leaders joshua wong and agnes chao
academic benitai and media mogul jimmy
ly have been jailed
samuel bickets an american lawyer was
imprisoned after an altercation with a
police officer during the protests
others like political activist nathan
law have been forced to live in exile
i left hong kong in june 2020 a few days
before the implementation of the
national security law and the law
criminalized free speech
it's a crime to stand against the
government now
for some people the national security
law made living in hong kong a far
riskier prospect but for global business
the impact of the law has been nuanced
[Music]
it's hard to understand how it will be
enforced and how someone could be on the
hook as a result of the national
security law so as a result of that a
lot of businesses became more quiet a
lot less outspoken and concerned about
what could hit them at any time i think
to be quite blunt the national security
law has been reasonable for the
financial sector it's been a good thing
for the financial sector and so far it
gives certainty and i think that
certainty gives a lot of investors
confidence in hong kong
that could have been shattered or was
shattered for some people
during the protests western companies
will need to take into account very
seriously
the changes happening in hong kong
including the erosion of the rule of law
the rule of law matters because it's the
assumption that the courts and
law enforcement operate separately to
the government in terms of international
contracts and the things that foremost
concern to businesses rule of law seems
intact and comfortable but in our latest
survey we've noted that pessimism has
started to creep in i don't think hong
kong has role flow anymore they can
easily manipulate political cases
i don't think
we are far away from the date that they
could also manipulate cases on
commercial arguments and make favorable
judgment to beijing
after six months of political disruption
in 2020 the covert 19 pandemic led the
hong kong government to impose a
fiercely isolationist zero covered
strategy that has further thrown into
question the city's future as a travel
and financial hub we have been seeing
strict social distancing rules in hong
kong we have been seeing strict
quarantine rules of up to three weeks we
have been seeing flight bans we have
been seeing hong kong being increasingly
isolated with the rest of the world
the zero covet policy implemented in
hong kong is one that clearly comes from
beijing but after two years watching the
rest of the world uh with the exception
of china really emerge from kovid and
learn to live with it people are really
tired and fed up
so it's created this mini exodus which
has really shifted the atmosphere
the data show the extent of the brain
drain from hong kong
many hong kongers have fled to the uk
while expat workers have permanently or
temporarily relocated to singapore or
tokyo or returned to their home
countries
the migration has fueled conversations
about whether alternative cities in asia
have expressed their ambitions to become
global financial centres could challenge
hong kong's dominance
there are three other cities in asia
that can credibly claim to be regional
financial hubs
singapore tokyo and shanghai
singapore has english and it's used to
bringing in expatriates and it's asia
light in the sense that it's very
comfortable for people to be there it's
definitely a place which is seen as the
sort of second option as a financial hub
in asia but singapore isn't perfect it
definitely does not have the financial
flows and the capital markets that hong
kong has while singapore has one of
asia's biggest wealth management sectors
its stock market is shallow and under
capitalized i don't think it's an
alternative to hong kong because simply
put it doesn't have the connectivity to
china that hong kong does
there's people moving to
tokyo
the idea that banks or investment banks
in tokyo are going to rival the american
banks or the chinese banks or become a
financial center threat to hong kong is
kind of ridiculous to be quite blunt
japan is the world's third largest
economy and tokyo has deep capital
markets
however tokyo has some big disadvantages
its finance sector actually has closer
financial ties with europe and north
america than it does with the rest of
asia
and japan's risk-averse financial
culture makes it unattractive for many
investors at the end of the day
you know the japanese financial sector
is really good at raising money for
japanese banks and japanese capital and
japanese companies
it is really bad at raising global
funds for anything outside of japan
shanghai is already a far bigger
financial centre than hong kong in terms
of overall value
it has asia's biggest stock markets and
a huge market for bond trading banking
and trade finance
the problem is that no city in mainland
china can realistically play a
significant international role china
does not have
an open market it does not have the
infrastructure that hong kong has to
handle this immense
flow of money and deals and people
moving about freely beijing demands
control over the flow of both money and
information
china severely limits access to media
from outside its borders
while currency controls stop people from
moving their money abroad
so i think that you have to you know
stop this
competition thing because really every
place has
natural advantages if you want to access
u.s capital you go to new york you don't
go to london
in the short term hong kong status as
the gateway to mainland china appears
unassailable but in the long term things
aren't quite so clear
in the rest of the world financial
centres thrive on freedom of information
of people and of capital and that
clashes with china's insistence or
control
[Music]
hong kong is becoming and arguably has
become a chinese city a china-focused
financial center which allows chinese
companies to list raise money
still do business with the rest of the
world on
chinese terms
if one is willing to accept that and
sees the opportunities associated with
that they have a strong future in hong
kong but for people expecting hong kong
to be like it used to then hong kong is
gone one hong kong government official
said to me china really just wants to
shut that window of foreign influence in
hong kong you know the idea of wylo or
foreigner or expat hong kong is actually
a funny thing we're going to look back
on this 30 years from now and wonder wow
how did it go on for so long
as china has growing confidence over its
more totalitarian technologically
sophisticated aurelian model there's no
need for them to keep hong kong as an
example for them to catch the west we
definitely haven't seen the end of the
line for hong kong as a financial center
beijing has still been giving support to
hong kong in terms of financial services
there's still a lot of dependency on
hong kong for its financial services for
its unique position
there is an awkwardness for american
companies
when it comes to china in terms of risks
and rewards
walking away from it is simply
not
a choice that they have is the financial
sector going to be bigger here in 10
years than it is today absolutely unless
we think china's going to stop growing
they're going to need more financial
help they're going to need to be
integrated further in the global
financial system and this is going to be
good for bankers here bankers here will
still be able to make
good money going forward hong kong is an
incredibly resilient place
and the entrepreneurial spirit of people
in hong kong will go a long way to keep
hong kong as a viable financial center
albeit somewhat diminished
hong kong is still asia's leading
financial centre even though its
reputation has been tarnished but it
should come as no surprise that beijing
has tightened its grip over the city
like it or not ultimately beijing is in
charge
and even though china needs
international finance in order to invest
trillions of dollars of household wealth
over the next few decades
it will require those intermediaries to
be subservient to the needs of the
chinese communist party
international business in china faces a
choice play by china's rules or leave
that makes some people uncomfortable but
for others it's a compromise they're
more than willing to make especially
those that see an opportunity to make
far more money in china